obviously going on this journey uh
with her heartbreak and then the mommy
issues
and then the relationship stuff with her
and lucifer
and then the teaming up and then the
betrayal
and then the fights it's like there's a
lot
yeah jam-packed in eight episodes yeah
for sure
get up
we're not done well let's talk about
those final moments is maize really team
michael right now
you know i think he's a means to an end
for her i think
when you have been pushed aside by
people that you love or care about
in her case with lucifer time and time
again when you are
not a consideration when they make
decisions
but they have always been for you when
you make decisions for the most part i
think
everyone has their limits and i think
mazukina's gotten to that point where
it's like listen i need a soul
this is the means to an end um obviously
there's an inch of guilt
there yeah she definitely obviously does
not intentionally want to hurt her
friends
but there's a betrayal between these two
that is just so hard for her to get over
it's this kind of roller coaster right
it's like the hurt the anger the pain
and then like the acceptance what do you
think
was the breaking moment was it when he
sort of pushed off her
her question being about whining a soul
or to you what was
that moment there's a first for
everything right
oh that's different we're angels you're
just a
demon i think it's twofold it's i think
it's that moment but it starts with the
fact that he lift her
and you see that in the beginning of the
season they had a giant
fight in season two
where she thought he was gonna leave
without her and he promises he's like i
never meant to hurt you i would never do
that to you
like and then he does
you know and and i think that's a very
hard betrayal to get over
for her and i'm not sure going into
season six if i'm honest that they ever
come back to where they were i don't
know
but i think even at the end of this
season
uh the other eight episodes there's
definitely obviously
they're in each other's lives but i but
i think her focus now is
uh building her life for her even
losing you know potentially chloe as a
friend
i think so i think you know there comes
a point where
you like i said you when you are
constantly outputting and giving
to people and giving their energy like
yourself
yeah you're giving your energy to them
and because i think a lot of strong
characters and a lot of strong women
like maze like you get
your people think you can you can handle
so much
but they don't see the behind the scenes
of what it takes for you to
work through that stuff there's this
very soft very vulnerable
core i think that maze is built over the
last five years
and i think that's kind of affecting
that wall now yeah i noticed and
let me know if i'm wrong but she so
lucifer has this ring on
and she sort of looks at this ring and
she's like disgusted she's like upset by
it
what was that exact moment well it's
symbolic it's the betrayal right
because we obviously see the backstory
in episode four
and where the ring came from and
now it's the it's this it's the
the what that ring symbolizes
which is a secret
and one of the biggest betrayals
to her and their in their friendship
because he knows her mommy issues he
knows her life he knows every single
part
um you know of her and how
i think what he doesn't know 100
percent is magical on earth with
humanity
growing and growing and growing you know
year to year
so the disgust comes from
basically knowing that he's had this lie
on his hand for all these years and he's
been right there in her face do you
think it's possible for her
to have a soul i hope so but i hope
her soul will be
um i i do think so because i think
what her soul will be will be something
that's come of her
um getting close to humans exploring
humanity um
finding love having heartbreak going
through all the things that
we do as people you know and and knowing
that
even though things don't maybe sometimes
work out the way you want to
so i hope she will have a soul in a
different way than her
that she ends up differently to her to
her mother yeah
i was gonna ask you how do you think she
would be affected
as a character having a soul like what
do you think what changes
would we potentially see well i think
you're kind of seeing the semblance of
it you know she's definitely
um she's more in touch with feelings
and she's learning you know that whole
situation with her and linda and amina
deal
it's like it wasn't about a boy it was
the fact that her friend
said she wouldn't date him and promised
her
and then did and again betrayal
so i think what you will see maybe
maybe is is a double-edged sword
is a more understanding of why people do
the things they do
but maybe her wrath will grow in ways
that like people have never seen before
and
at the tail end of the season there's a
hurt
and a loss for her that
you'll see her react in her most demonic
way
ever very bloody very gory very
yeah are you talking about in 5b
wow so yeah we tend to think that
there's going to be a lot more
fight scenes like a more aggressive maze
is it does it get
there's one fight scene in particular at
the end of this year
this season that is it's it's basically
the the the
the ignition to that is
is hurt and and
she's feeling and seeing a loss in a way
like she's never seen before
you know human life whatever whatever
whatever
she's tortured people she's tortured
souls
she's happy but this uh
this this will you'll see
you'll see how hard maize will go for
the people she loves
yeah in that particular episode it was
really
difficult for me um
for a number of reasons um
uh both personally and as the actor
and personally because you know because
i'm a mother
trixie or charlie uh maybe and then it
leads into
um just one of the bloodiest
uh violent things i've done
on the show
i do want to ask about her in a mena
deal though is there a love
connection that could be brewing
once again sort of i mean i feel like
that was teased there was the call back
i think she was trying to basically like
you know it's that thing where you
um gosh we've all been there you break
up you lose someone
that you really really care about is
there a world in which eve returns
yeah she i mean she does she does return
to the show
i think in a similar way to lucifer
she's tailored to
to eve lucifer for you know
nostalgia old history um and
and eve in a way that's representative
of like a new stage in their life and
and an acceptance that someone loves me
for all of me
eve loves both maze and mazzakin for all
the reasons that make them
masochine amazed so it's um
yeah i think there's there's that
connection there but it's definitely
confusing for her when she comes back
for sure
would you want to see her end up with
eve eve would have to earn it
and does she do a good job in 5b
i think i think she's trying you know
and
i think that it takes
a lot for me to like like me
to trust that someone is
going to show up and be there you know
and and i think because she's gone
through so much like hurt and
disappointment and betrayal
that is sometimes with people and
you know it's like hitting a brick wall
with her you know
because there is so much learned
behavior
that she's like see i
let myself be vulnerable again and look
what happened and look what happened and
look what happens so
but like i said those two are tailored
to each other it's
you know the heart wants what the heart
wants so i think there's that
pull and push what would it take for
lucifer
and mazzakin to get back to who they
were like what would it take
to salvage that friendship
time um i guess
a soul maybe to understand it
i think a conversation and an
acknowledgement
of things that were
done and an apology maybe
i'm not sure that their lives are going
in the same direction
where that work necessarily is able to
happen it's like you
you know maze wants to go and find your
independence
sounds you know lucifer and like that
relationship
but where does that lead her you know
and then lucifer
is trying to do right with chloe and you
know
he's got his own whole sort of thing
going on as well
and it would it would take them
prioritizing each other
yeah eventually which i which you know i
hope happens in season six
i think one of the most special moments
of the whole season was the fact that
may's got to meet
her mom and her mom passes away
how do you think going into 5b and even
in even season six that that really
deeply
affects her i always get emotional when
i talk about the spot
sorry um i think
and not for any other reason other than
the fact that i'm a mother and so
you know i wish i could hug you
i know i know and and and i think
thank you i think
getting over that
we're all children at the end of the day
who
you know you want to be cared about and
loved even the toughest strongest people
is you want that parent or someone
parental figure or just some
older figure in your life
that is there to guide you when you need
it
i remember doing that scene because
she's still such a child going like
where were you
like i need you watched me you want you
knew i was here
you knew i was here trying to figure
this out and you did nothing like you
didn't show up you weren't there for me
i think that's why that
story line with linda and you know her
daughter is so
important because it's like you have the
opportunity to not go down the path that
my mother and i did
so just take it just take it show up
just just do it
let's talk about god showing up at the
very end
oh my gosh that beautiful man
is there a time jump when 5b picks up or
do you does it pick up
right at that very moment yeah i know it
picks up
um it definitely picks up and there's
you know
mazzakin and hem have some great
scenes together um and that is all tied
in with michael
yeah so it's like all the celestial kind
of
supernaturally demon angel god
they're all kind of like just this
they're churning how does god feel
about michael well you know
michael is someone who praises someone's
vulnerability so there is a closeness
there and obviously it's his child
and i think there is a closeness to
michael and god that
lucifer doesn't have but maybe wants
yeah and they have beautiful there's
beautiful beautiful scenes between uh
tom and dennis this season how will
having a season six
affect do you think your character the
most i think
where she leaves off at the end of the
season that
i think fans will be really happy from
i've i've
heard some rumors you know or ideas i
shouldn't say rumors ideas from the
writer's room
but i think if anyone deserves
real honest to god like happiness and
like a happy ending it's this character
i i i hope i'm just like she has been
through
[Music]
it